okay you want me to be honest I just
don't think two dogs which your
spaghetti like that hi there
I'm Lucy I'm Gus your name
what Oh I'm Oliver I'm Fiona and today
we're gonna be watching famous movie
dogs
oh that's Doug from up I love this movie
my name is Doug I have just met you and
I love you I love old people but you
have to be really careful not to knock
them over he made me this collar so that
I may talk squirrel did some girl wins
girls very accurate portrayal squirrel a
- since a nose aka obsessed with
squirrels Oh Lady and the [ __ ] where do
I start I don't mean to be the bad dog
but this scene it's just it's a little
pretentious and she doesn't even touch
the meatball whoa there's music in this
why is that human squeezing - shoe boxes
together can I have some spaghetti well
this is so romantic I would totally go
on this date except to replace the other
dog with a second bowl of spaghetti Oh
Marley and Me get the tissues out no I
just peed on the rug someone needs to
clean that up
so real dogs of food is that good okay
now can we put on the cat fails
compilation i love getting in trouble
but i also love being a good dog this
movie is so confusing oh I love dogs I
really enjoyed this one quizzing before
we attack each other and tear ourselves
to shreds like a pack of maniacs
gorgeous hair and makeup in this movie
is that I'm just realizing this now as I
listen is that Ed Norton she sees the
future huh no she understands TV sorry
am I not allowed up here I also just
need to say that everyone in this room
is my best friend outbreak of snap fever
rips through the city of Mecca socket no
I am listening there's there's just a
pretzel stuck under the keys here and I
can see it if someone could help me that
just please
okay where's the dark aren't we watching
dog movies I'm getting bored we don't go
for a walk soon
[Music]
super-realistic slobberin in this scene
I cannot stop looking at this light over
here it feels like I can't look away
help help help this makes me want to
chase something this shirt is so itchy
what anyone I hear mind running away
from me so I could chase them yeah yeah
I mean I guess this is realistic I'm
sorry this video just feels super
strange I think you guys are running out
of ideas that's it we're done okay good
because I have to go to the bathroom and
this time it's number two
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part